everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and this is the first video
of many in a series of Bobby Fischer's
USA championship games to cover the
upcoming graphic novel Bobby Fischer the
knight who killed Kings now this comes
to us from 1963 in my opinion the most
dominant performance of any US
Championship Series Bobby Fischer played
11 games and he won all 11 games and he
literally just destroyed everyone that
got in this path what's interesting to
me is nowadays once you even get close
to getting you know crown champion if
you're maybe a pointer to as far as the
final standings most people will tend to
play for drawls they don't want to lose
even that half a point the games don't
really tend to be that exciting to me
but Bobby Fischer he won by three and a
half points and even till the end he
tried to win every single game so he was
11 for 11 in this particular game he
played against Larry Evans now another
reason I think this game is so fantastic
is only two years earlier again this is
1963 in 1961 Bobby Fischer released the
article bust to the Kings gambit now
that article was actually it came out in
the American chess quarterly which is a
chess magazine that's edited by none
other than Larry Evans so Bobby Fischer
not only knew how Larry Evans played but
he also knew that he edited the magazine
that published the bus to the Kings
gambit which is Bobby Fischer's if
you're not too familiar with it is an
article that he wrote after he lost to
Spassky who played the Kings gambit and
beat Bobby Fischer he pretty much said
the Kings gambit is flawed now keep in
mind that in particular in his article
he did go over the pawn to e4 pawn e5
and after pawn to f4 in the exchange
Knight comes to f3 now in the actual
game that he plays today and Larry Evans
that we're gonna be covering he does
play a different movie plays Bishop to
c4 but it's very interesting to note
that even at the end of the bus to the
Kings gambit
Bobby Fischer talked about he said even
if white tries a different move and in
this case Bishop tc4 he said that he
will only lose differently so he pretty
much wrote an article saying that the
Kings gambit is flawed he's now playing
an opponent in the 1963 US Championship
that he knows is very familiar with that
and he decides to play that opening
against him which i think is phenomenal
um mostly just because I think it's kind
of a slap in the face basically just
saying I know I'm better than you I'm
going to play an opening that we both
know is inferior that you should win and
I'm still going to beat you because I'm
Bobby Fischer and I'm better than you at
chess so we'll go ahead and get into it
it does start with Pawnee for Pawnee 5
upon f4 again this is the Kings gambit
line and Larry Evans playing the black
pieces decided to capture and accept and
he takes here on f4 now from here Bobby
Fischer had two ideas he could have gone
with he did have the most common which
is Knight to f3 trying to control the
center of the board
later on he can castle on the King side
put his rook on the semi open file for
the F file but he actually decided to
play Bishop to c4 this is his favorite
it very a ssin for the King's gambit
accepted line really putting a lot of
pressure on this f7 Square and he was
also very comfortable which many people
are not after the Queen comes down to h4
forcing the King here to come to f1
white no longer has the ability to
castle so it takes someone very skilled
to be able to play in the situation
knowing that his king is not going to
have the safety that it would after he
would have played Knight to f3 from here
Larry Evans plays pawn to d6 a very
common move from black in the Kings
gambit line whether it's accepted or not
really allowing this LightSquared bishop
to get involved into the game also for
black he has to keep in mind what is he
going to be attacking this white King
here on f1 it's going to be really hard
for him to come to the Queen side he's
going to be somewhat weak on the King
side so black if you really could he
would like to you know he already has
his major piece out here on h4 he would
really like to get his LightSquared
Bishop he'd also like to get his Knight
here on
ei developed and he would like to castle
on the queenside and then start to focus
all of his energy in all of his pieces
attacking the King here on the King on
the Kings side for white from here Bobby
Fisher developed his Knight to c3
against simple development move from
Bobby Fisher trying to control the
center of the board here especially
these light squares
especially this d5 square and Larry
Evans played Bishop to e6 now I do want
to touch on this because so many chess
players any time they see a piece that
they can exchange they do so
automatically and then they just try to
get to an endgame and they really don't
start to think about strategy if you
look at this before Larry Evans plays
Bishop to e6 Bobby Fischer has a
distinct lead in development meaning
that he has these two minor pieces
trying to control the center of the
board and it black is coming from behind
as far as development now he is up in
material he does have this pawn here on
f4 but Larry Evans is really going to
try to you know come back as far as the
development standpoint if you were to
come to e6 and Bobby Fischer right away
exchanges after Larry Evans takes back
he can always bring this pawn to e5
solidifying that pawn chain really
controlling the dark squares in the term
of the board as you can see here Bobby
Fischer no longer has that control of
the center that he did before he now is
allowing you know Larry Evans to have
both of his Center pawns involved into
the game he'd really like to keep you
know some pressure here from a piece on
c4 so instead of exchanging right away
he decides the best move is to play
Queen to e2 meaning if Larry Evans
wanted to exchange right away let's say
Bishop takes on c4 then after the
exchange back on c4 with the Queen
capturing then the Queen is still very
active and Bobby Fischer still has that
lead in development Larry Evans only has
one pawn and they're showing the board
and Bobby Fischer has a much better game
here so obviously Bobby Fischer makes
very very accurate decisions on this
chess board but even in your own game
make sure that you're not jumping to
conclusions you're not trying to
exchange as quick as you can but instead
you're really trying to figure out
what's going to be best would it even be
better if they captured my piece first
and then I recaptured with another piece
now from here Larry Evans plays pawn to
c6 one of his other options that he
could have played is Knight to d7
getting ready to castle on the Queen
side which is going to come inevitably
later on to the game sweetie plays pawn
to c6 and white plays Knight to f3
eventually this was bound to come
developing again another minor piece
into the game and gaining a tempo here
the black king queen scuse me on h4 is
going to have to get kicked back and so
again Bobby Fischer is down the material
but he's going to lead substantially as
far as a development standpoint now the
Queen's going to come back to e7
probably would have been a little bit
more aggressive if you would have come
back to you know h6 but he does decide
to come back to e7 he is still ahead and
material but Bobby Fischer presses on he
knows that he has a lead in development
any time you have a lead in development
you want to continue to push forward you
don't want to stay back and play passive
because then your entire advantage
starts to fall apart so he plays pawn to
d4 again that's about as aggressive
pushing forward as you can get and from
here black plays Bishop takes on c4
again trying to try to take away some of
the pressure that Bobby Fischer's
putting in the middle taking away this
Bishop here on c4 as we talked about
before Bobby Fischer can now recapture
with his Queen on c4 now as you can see
with this move from pawn to d4 he also
has allowed this dark square Bishop here
to have a discovered attack on this pawn
on f4 looking to regain that material
back that he lost at the beginning so if
you can think about if Bobby Fischer has
a distinct advantage in development if
he can gain back the material that he
lost early on he's going to have a very
very good game so a black really has two
options here one's vadym will go over
and then one's a little bit better he
would like to hold on to this material
on f4 now a lot of times people would
look at and say you know why doesn't he
play b5 well two main reasons one also
keep in mind he does want to castle on
the Queen side and they really start to
attack the white king on the King side
but this will also be a mistake because
after the Knight takes on b5 White's
going to have a hard problem if he cap
sure's here back on b5 with his pawn
then white can now play Queen to d5 and
Black's going to lose a lot of material
if he tries to you know defend his rook
bringing his knight out he's going to
lose his knight there's no way for him
to defend this rook here on a8 unless
again he wants to lose another piece
bringing his queen to b7 so this would
actually be a mistake again not only
will he lose material but he's also
weakening his Queen side here the really
only good move that he has here is to
play pawn to g5 again we're not really
too worried about in this situation
Larry Evans doesn't matter if he you
know weakens his King side because again
he's looking to castle on the Kings side
or excuse me on the Queen side
now from here White's going to continue
with pawn to e5 again really starting to
push forward and put a lot of pressure
on Larry Evans now Larry Evans decides
to decline this which i think is a
better move if you would have exchanged
you know a lien development with open
spaces against Bobby Fischer you just
really don't want to do it but he
decides to solidify his pawn chain a
little bit play pawn to d5 decline the
exchange and really start to look
towards an endgame here this Queen side
is now very solidified he can now start
to really work on the Kings side of the
board so Bobby Fischer his queen is
being attacked so he brings it back to
d3 probably the the most aggressive
square he doesn't want to be too passive
with where he moves this but again he
doesn't want to move it back to let's
say b3 he realizes that there's not
going to be a lot of activity that he
can actually do on the Queen side so he
pretty much knows that Larry Evan needs
to come to the Kings side and that's
really what's opening up right now so
since he has a lead in development he
might as well start to shift his focus
on to the Kings side since the Queen
side is pretty much locked up here what
once this pawn chain has been locked
down with this pawn moved to d5 here now
black decides to get his knight involved
into the game he plays Knight to a6
again really looking to bounce this
Queen off the board you know personally
I think he should have geared towards
moving it toward
the kingside but in this situation I
don't think it's too bad later on he can
really you know start to get his night
to c7 he definitely wants to get that
involved into the game earlier than not
or he's going to have this night hanging
out here on a six while all the actions
going on on the kingside so from here
white plays Knight to e2 now if you look
at what can Bobby Fischer do it's not
going to do a lot of good to bring his
bishop here to d2 again a King move
isn't going to do too much his rook here
on h1 is rook here on a1 aren't doing
too much his queen can't really do too
much who really wants to start you know
focusing on the kingside his night here
on t3 can't really do anything on the
Queen side so that's why he plays Knight
to e2 really looking towards attacking
here on the King side now Larry Evans we
talked about before he plays Knight to
before trying to kick this Queen here
away and Bobby Fischer just retreats
back to d1 again still a little bit
passive you know he could have always
played you know Queen to c3 or Queen to
b3 but again I think Bobby Fischer
realized that he really wanted to focus
on the kingside there's no reason to
extend your Queen over to b3 c3 is just
going to be you know away from the
action when everything goes down on the
Kings side so he does move his queen
back too deep as we will expect Larry
Evans decides to castle on the Queen
side and now Bobby Fischer plays pawn to
c3 he really wants to go ahead and kick
this night away right now it's just kind
of a nuisance there's really only one
square for him to go and he kicks it
back to a6 now Larry Evans really you
know later on CH will want to get this
to c7 but right now it's kind of an
in-between move to play pawn to c3 just
kick it away because it was kind of a
nuisance just hanging out there on b4
now Bobby Fischer can continue with his
planning he's going to play pawn to h4
it would be a mistake here if black
actually took because then Bobby Fischer
could come in and play
you know rook takes on h4 and then he's
going to gain this material back here on
f4 but instead Larry Evans decides to
play the better move and that's just to
continue to push forward start to put a
lot of pressure on
Bobby Fischer and play pawn to g4
kicking this night away Bobby Fischer
decides to play this night back to h2
later on you know he could have always
played it 2 e 1 if you wanted to buy
decided in this case to play H 2 still
putting a lot of pressure on this pawn
on g4
now from here Larry Evans played pawn to
h5 solidifying this pawn here on g4 if
you wanted to do anything with it later
on and Bobby Fischer takes back with his
night here on f4 so as far as material
if we look at it both sides are
definitely equal in material as far as
you know both of their sides I would
call it about equal simply because why
definitely leads in development by his
King is also a lot more susceptible to
any sort of King side attack and the
King for black is pretty comfortable
he's Castle queenside it's going to be
very difficult for white anytime soon to
come over and attack this King and put
any sort of pressure on the black king
now from here actually feel like Larry
Evans made a mistake and the game he
played Queen takes on h4 and while he
does immediately look like he does game
material as well look at it he actually
does not and so because of that I think
it actually would have been better for
him to play as something a little bit
safer he could have played you know
Queen to d7 he could have started to
develop his other pieces he could have
played Bishop to g7 if he wanted to you
know he could have started focusing on
Knight to c7 but instead he really
started to overextend himself and Bobby
Fischer just took absolute control of
that and started to again put a lot of
pressure on black and black really
didn't have a lot of control after this
move so again Larry Evans plays Queen to
h4 and Bobby Fischer plays King to g1
now he does this merely because one he
wants to protect it behind this g2 pawn
but more importantly once he moves this
Knight here from h2 we have a discovered
attack the rook is now attacking the
Queen and he wants to have a defender
and
the most logical piece in this situation
is the king there on G once just keep
that in mind the night here is
threatening you know he could come to f1
if he wanted to he could come to f3
all of these attacking the Queen he
could even come here and attack here on
g4 if you wanted to again all of these
attacking the Queen here on h4 from here
black decided to play Knight to h6 again
trying to defend this pawn here on g4
and Bobby Fischer just simply plays
Knight back to f1 again discovered
attack on this Queen on h4 Larry Evans
is forced to retreat and he plays back
with Queen to e7 kind of where he was
before before it captured on H Bobby
Fischer can now take back the material
with Knight takes on h5 and again Bobby
Fischer as far as development standpoint
is doing much better Black has both of
his Knights on the rim he hasn't boot on
the a file and the H file typically not
what you want to do you want to have
your Knights more centralized or more
active as far as you know this night
here on h5 is a lot more active for
white here also he is yet to you know
his bishop here on F eights not doing
much it's going to be a lot easier for
white to get his pieces involved into
the game then black blacks black doesn't
have a lot of you know threats that he
has where white does have a lot of
threats where he's still you know
threatening all these pieces you know he
does have this great outpost he can come
to f6 if he wants to at any time he's
threatening with his dark squared Bishop
and he does have all these semi-open
files and this long open file that he
can attack with very easily but from
here black plays rook to g8 and Bobby
Fischer plays Knight to g3 Bobby Fischer
won the greatest thing that he does in
his chess games is all of his pieces
work together so all of his knights
always work together he does have you
know this rook here on h1 defending this
Knight all of his pieces really really
do work together from here Larry Evans
plays rook to g6 and Bobby Fischer plays
Knight to f4 attacking
this rook making it go somewhere and it
just comes down to g5 now keep in mind
after this next move because Bobby
Fischer plays Bishop to e3 again one of
the things you always want to think
about is have your minor pieces attack
and you want to have your major pieces
the fin and support those early on into
the game later down the road you want
your major pieces doing a lot of the
attacking if you still have them but
very very important to have your minor
pieces kind of out in front and then
your major pieces to support them so the
last piece that as far as development
the Bobby Fischer had to do was bring
his Bishop to e3 the most aggressive
score he can do and then later on he's
going to bring his Queen to d2 again
trying to support all of his people
Larry Evans now plays Knight to c7 I
particularly think this is a little late
I would like to see him Larry Evans play
this much earlier I think that the
knight here is a little late getting to
the party I think it would have been
better if he played you know pawn to f6
trying to break up the center of the
board really start to get his other
pieces involved into the game but
nonetheless he plays Knight to c7 and
Bobby Fischer plays Queen to d2 as we
talked about now that only is he's
supporting this
he's also threatening you know Knight to
d5 he does have the discovered attack
against the rook there on g5
he's also allowing his rookie B wants
you to come over into the game he does
have this semi open file for F so a lot
of threats that Bobby Fischer has just
by playing this Queen to d2 having his
major pieces support his minor pieces
here now Larry Evans decided to bring
his rook back to g8 again he saw that
discovered attack and decided to go
ahead and opt out and move that from
here Bobby Fischer plays Knight to e2 as
we talked about before all of his pieces
work together so he still has both of
his knights you know supporting each
other but also he has more discovered
attack so he now has three different
pieces lying down on this h6 square and
it's going to be very very difficult for
this night here on h6 to live through
the end of the game particularly because
there's not many
squares for him to go to he can't come
to f5 he'll die he can't come to g4
there's a piece he can't go to g8
there's a piece and he can't come to f7
because there is a piece Larry Evans now
decides to play f6 you know again trying
to break up the center of the board he
realizes he would like to bring his
knight back to f7 but he realizes that
there's not enough time to do that Bobby
Fischer goes ahead and gobbles that up
and after the Queen takes here on f6 he
comes down in captures with his bishop
here on h6 now again there's not many
great things that Larry Evan could do in
this situation you know he could always
exchange pieces here with his [ __ ] up
on h6 and then you know Bobby Fischer
could recapture with his queen or his
rook here from h1 to h6 he decides
instead even though he is down in
material so go ahead and bring his
Bishop to d6 centralize it try to get
some sort of counter play he knows he's
down he needs to make something happen
Bobby Fischer now plays rook to f1 any
time you have an advantage go ahead and
get your last piece involved into the
game and do it with tempo so attacking
this Queen forcing the Queen to move
somewhere again all of his pieces are
defended - this Queen on d2 which can't
really get to anyway so all of this
piece is really really working well
together
the Queen's forced to come back to e6
and now Bobby Fischer plays Bishop to f4
again he doesn't really mine now
you know exchanging these bishops here
on the dark squares and Larry Evans
decides instead of exchanging to go
ahead and bring his rook to e8
Bobby Fischer now brings his rook to h6
as we talked about before he does have
all the support from the bishop here on
f4 and the Queen here on d2 now he's
really starting to get a lot more active
and starts a lot put a lot more pressure
on Larry Evans and the King side here so
Larry Evans decides to go ahead and
capture there on f4 now it would
actually be a mistake if Bobby fixture
decided to you know take with you know
take the Queen here on East
because after you know Larry Evans comes
down and captures here on the - then
after the exchange here on e8 both sides
are actually equals you can look at
material both sides are equal so Bobby
Fischer definitely has to be careful
about how he captures but instead he
definitely chooses the right way after
Larry Evans decides and takes on f4 he
decides not to take the Queen right away
there's no need
he just captures with his queen here on
f4 again still maintaining a lot of
pressure all this piece is still working
very very well together and just kind of
waiting till the end of the game because
he is up so much in material now really
there's not much for Larry Evans to do
he does bring his queen back to e7 Bobby
Fischer now plays rook to f6 now I this
is kind of the end of the game and Bobby
Fischer realizes that you know he's
already won if you've ever been taught
or had you know chess lessons one of the
things you always say is you always want
to rook your queen in your rook to be on
the same file and you would actually
want them to be in this order
you know rook Queen rook as far as you
know how you have them on the file but
actually I think he missed a move here I
think that's excuse me Knight - you know
f5 was actually a stronger move you know
it's attacking the Queen there on e7 the
next move he does have is Knight to d6
again forking one of the rooks on e8
gaining more material now I know it
doesn't really matter he's going to win
the game either way he's up an entire
piece which anytime Bobby Fischer's up
an entire piece he's probably to win but
I do think this was a small inaccuracy
not that it really mattered because he
again was on autopilot he kind of knew
he was going to win but there's
something to think about even the best
players even when they're winning don't
always play the best move so think about
all the different options that you have
in your own game but Bobby Fischer
played rook to f6 and Larry Evans plays
Knight to e6 kind of a last-ditch effort
Bobby Fischer plays Queen to e5 and then
the knight excuse me comes down to g5
and now it's kind of over from here
bobby fischer's now how to exchange
pieces off there's not much you know
that Larry Evans can do here if you're
down if you're up in material excuse me
you definitely want to trade down
because the more you trade down the
bigger of an advantage that you do have
so Bobby Fischer decides you know what
I'm just going to exchange off make it
now bring this night - excuse me his
rook - f8 and after the exchange here on
f8 Larry Evans decides to resign to the
game he's just down too much material
and there's just not enough material on
the board for any sort of counter-attack
or to do anything any threatening -
Bobby Fischer so a fantastic game one of
the most dominant u.s. championship
performances that we've ever seen going
11 for 11 trying to win every single
game if you're playing white or black
just phenomenal and I think it's just
fun that he did play the Kings gambit
against Larry Evans who who knows so
much about the Kings gambit and the bus
- the Kings gambit that Bobby Fischer
wrote so hope you guys enjoy the video
again this is one of the videos in the
series that we're going to be doing on
the u.s. championship for Bobby Fischer
so definitely check out those in the
future and let me know your feedback and
I'll see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching